[Music]
the high-pitched whine of a hungry
mosquito may be annoying but it also
hides a scientific mystery how do
mosquitoes fly almost all insects can
fly but for a long time no one could
work out how aeroplanes were invented
based on relatively simple aerodynamics
but when people tried to apply those
theories to insects like bumble bees
they didn't work compared to a plane
insects were too heavy for their tiny
wings to keep them in the air it took
decades to start figuring out how
insects fly but scientists did
eventually discover their key trick
something known as a leading-edge vortex
as the air rushes past an insect swing a
tornado like vortex forms on top at the
very front edge this swirl of rushing
air decreases the pressure above the
wing meaning that the insect gets a
little extra lift to keep them up but
for mosquitoes things aren't quite as
simple fair wings flap extremely fast
but only through a very shallow angle
only about 40 degrees half that of a bee
that shallow movement shouldn't be
enough for them to fly using a leading
edge vortex alone solving this new
mystery took eight slow motion cameras
simultaneously recording a single flying
mosquito from eight different angles
this footage here almost 700 times
slower than its actual speed was used to
create a 3d model that could show
exactly how the wing was moving this
enabled researchers to model how air
flows over the wing in flight as
expected they saw a leading edge vortex
at the front of the wing but they also
saw something new another vortex forming
at the back edge of the wing a trailing
edge vortex as the back edge of the wing
flips around it captures the swirling
wake of the previous flap allowing it to
recapture some of that energy the
formation of this second vortex again on
the upper surface of the wing provide
extra lift for the mosquito while this
may solve the problem of how mosquitoes
fly it doesn't answer the question of
why they use this technique their high
speed shallow angle flapping doesn't
seem to be very power efficient the high
frequency does make a noise though and
that could be useful for things like
attracting a mate whatever the reason
the mosquitoes trick could one day be
stolen by humans perhaps for use in the
design of increasingly smaller flying
machines let's just hope they make a
slightly less annoying sound
[Music]
you